the real forefront of the coronavirus is
now testing and that's why we're talking
about it more and more vaccines are a
year away if things go well for
widespread use healthcare workers may
have an emergency use vaccine in the
fall if things go perfectly we've got
dozens of treatments being tested
nothing so far has been definitively
effective so that it becomes the
standard of care in terms of existing
drugs for off-label usage we'll talk a
little bit later about the latest news
with hydroxychloroquine there's no magic
bullet right now other than social
distancing and widespread testing now
the amount of disinformation and lies
from the Trump administration about
testing is staggering and because
testing is much more opaque than
something like deaths they are getting
away with a lot of these lies so which
that that's why I want to explain it to
you today so very early on we were told
we're gonna be testing millions and
millions of people per week we were told
by the end of March we will have 27
million people tested it is now nearly
the end of April and we have only tested
four million people okay we're a month
past when they said we would have tested
27 million we've only tested four
million people the numbers are public
they're released daily you can find them
at covent tracking calm now Donald Trump
is insisting that we have the best tests
and we are doing the most testing now
neither is true we're dealing with
possible combinations of both false
positive and false negatives with tests
anecdotally but more importantly in
terms of per capita we've done about
12,000 tests per million people in the
United States that puts us 42nd in the
world in per capita testing now there
will be people who will say come on
David you're you know we're 42nd if you
include the Faroe Islands and Gibraltar
as countries they are tiny they
shouldn't really be part of the equation
fine if you take out the tiny countries
right if you don't include the Channel
Islands if you don't include Aruba we
are still only 28th in the world in per
capita testing so the reopening
guidelines say that to even move to
phase one
States must have quote the ability to
quickly set up safe and efficient
screening and testing sites for
symptomatic individuals and trace
contacts of coded positive results the
ability to test syndromic and influenza
like illness indicated persons for
coronavirus as well as the trace
contacts of those individuals and
sentinel surveillance sites that are
screening for asymptomatic cases and
contacts for people positive for corona
virus in practice no state has that
right now but notice that there are no
metrics there there are no metrics for
the number of tests if they came out and
said states must be able to test two
percent of their population on a daily
basis okay and and must be doing so in
order to move on to Phase one now we're
talking now we have something tangible
to talk about the real single important
question right now is when will actual
tests completed increase because they
won't tell us this on Monday when this
was asked dr. Burks put up picture put
up a graph of labs that can process
tests that doesn't tell us the number of
tests that we must be doing and when we
will be able to do them testing centers
don't mean much if they're not
processing tests how many tests are we
doing how many tests can we do and do we
need to be doing in order to move on to
phase one sometimes the Trump
administration will say there are enough
tests out there to double capacity
capacity doesn't mean that the tests can
actually be done it means the materials
for the tests are out there but we need
to actually be processing tests Trump
regularly talks about tests like
exciting new iPhones take a look say an
incredible tests called the ID'd now
point of care diagnostic tests and it's
fantastic so it's that one from with
this business is this a hot one till
about two days from now because we do
have a saliva test that just came out
and that can be self administered and
it's said to be fantastic yeah lots of
exciting new product
for coronavirus customers yet the one
number that matters which is tests being
done is not going up this is not a
secret cove in tracking comm tells you
each day how many tests are being done
and as you can see we're telling where
we put the numbers up on the screen all
the way from the start of April which is
what we're looking at the tests per day
are basically unchanged we are testing
between a hundred and twenty and a
hundred and sixty thousand people a day
Trump recently claimed tests done are
doubling weekly they aren't here's the
data I'm showing it to you and in the
meantime we had a record number of
deaths in the United States yesterday so
very clearly we're not ready to reopen I
want to reopen as badly as everybody I'm
sick of being home the the life we lived
in January seems so foreign at this
point but we're just not there and if
the 1918 flu pandemic tells us anything
it's that if you open prematurely you
are worse off in the medium and long
term it's painful to remain closed I get
it but we are simply not ready when we
reached a new high in deaths yesterday
and we have not increased actual tests
done remember capacity is a code word
for BS tests done have not increased
during the month of April we're simply
not ready if you disagree with me by
missing something let me know I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman one of our sponsors
Nord VPN is giving you 70% off a
three-year plan which comes out to just
a little over three bucks a month and
you'll get an extra month free when you
go to Nord VPN comm slash David Pakman
or just go to their site and use the
coupon code David Pakman it's 20/20
there is really no reason not to be
using a VPN not using a VPN means you
are not taking your internet safety
seriously I use Nord VPN almost any time
I'm using the Internet it hides your IP
address when you're browsing online
keeps you safe from hackers keeps
websites from tracking your browsing
activity many advantages and Nord VPN is
the
trusted VPN in the game they don't log
your internet activity like many other
VPNs do their servers are super fast and
you can even use it on your phone Nord
VPN is giving you 70% off a three-year
plan that's just over three bucks a
month plus an extra month free when you
go to Nordby pn comm slash david pakman
i've put a link right underneath the
video or just go to their website and
use the coupon code david pakman